guess this is goodbye oh that's stupid
law this isn't fair
we love Disney movies but we gotta admit
that some of their endings are a little
cringe-worthy the Little Mermaid and
Cinderella don't seem quite so romantic
after you've grown up but whether it's a
princess giving up her family to marry a
guy she hardly knows or a movie not
answering any of our burning questions
we have some opinions we love frozen but
there are a couple things about the
ending that leave us a little shocked
Hans did a complete 180 on Anna after
acting like her dream guy if only there
was someone out there who loved you we
know he was the secret villain but it
really came out of nowhere
Anna being the one to say to Hans you
know this isn't for me might have been a
more powerful way for honored to take
control of her destiny and now for Elsa
after she returns to arendelle the
villagers seem more than happy to take
her back but would you have been so
willing to trust a queen who has barely
made public appearances and who can turn
everything to ice if she loses control
we know by now that Elsa is a good
person
but the villagers hardly got to see that
we also love mallanna
but now he's ending could have been a
bit better his hook gets destroyed after
he finally realizes that helping Moana
and making up for his mistakes is more
important than his all-powerful weapon
but just after he realizes this and
might actually change for the better
he gets a brand new hook
we're happy still friends with Moana and
seems to use his powers more responsibly
by the end of the movie but he still
should have lost his hook for good he
wasn't even the one who put to feed his
heart back
it was Moana for a movie was such a
headstrong unique main character how did
braves ending end up being a little
boring everything we thought would
happen did and Merida spent the whole
movie trying not to get married so she
didn't and by the end of the movie
Merida just goes right back to her usual
ways but with a little less hatred for
her mother we're definitely not saying
she should have gotten married but
there's not a whole lot of growth or
change here for a story about female
empowerment Merida deserves a sequel so
we can get a better look at this
incredible character Penelope deciding
to ditch Ralph and Ralph breaks the
internet for a new life in slaughter
Rayce is super sad and also a bit
strange it's gonna be great found a
dream game yeah does she really want to
spend her time in a polluted crime
ridden videogame world to each their own
but there's not a whole lot of beauty to
enjoy or even new friends to make other
than shank and her crew but at least
Penelope didn't go turbo and can always
return to her game if slaughter race
also gets too boring okay so let's do a
quick recap of the Little Mermaid Ariel
makes a deal with Ursula follows Prince
Erik onto land fights for his love and
then finally her father grants her legs
so she could marry the prince of her
dreams except she hardly knows him and
she's basically forced to live a human
life now did she ever think to herself
what if it doesn't work out since there
are sequels we know things end up just
fine but it seems like Ariel is quite
the risk-taker there's a pretty
depressing moment at the end of Beauty
and the Beast after many years trapped
us furniture the beasts staff finally
turns back into humans after the curse
is broken
[Music]
but we don't get to see how they'll have
to deal with their messy lives after
being gone for so long and they also go
right back to being staff in a house
they were trapped in for years does that
seem fair it beats being a clock or a
candle but we sure hope the Beast is
generous with paid vacation days
the ending to Tarzan is a bit of a
downer first Clayton is hanged by the
neck in some vines which seems a bit
dark for a Disney movie but then Jane
decides to stay with Tarzan a human
raised by gorillas that grew up in the
wild and live with him on an island we
imagine them setting off somewhere and
starting a nature conservatory but
apparently living in trees with gorillas
is just as good of an option we like to
think they met somewhere in the middle
and are out there living and nature
friendly but still human life most of
Aladdin is about a poor boy pretending
he's a prince so he can get out of the
slums and marry Princess Jasmine and it
all builds up - Jasmine's father the
Sultan realizing he can just change the
law and that his daughter doesn't have
to marry a prince after all could you
imagine what the movie would have been
like if Aladdin had tried wooing Jasmine
as himself while convincing the Sultan
to let him a commoner marry the princess
we're not saying we didn't enjoy the
movie as it is but the Sultan sooner
realizing he should just change the law
would have saved everyone a whole lot of
trouble just when you think there's an
actual chance that the Hunchback of
Notre Dame's Quasimodo could end up with
Esmeralda she falls in love with a guard
named Phoebus and Quasimodo is forced to
watch them be happy as a couple he
leaves the Cathedral at the end and is
seemingly celebrated for being a hero
but it's sad that he even had to become
a hero for people to accept him plus
when Quasimodo and Esmeralda leave the
cathedral for the streets the streets of
Paris are looking pretty spotless who
had time to clean up all that mess
the ending of inside out is lovely and
realistic but it makes us sad knowing
that now Riley's days as a happy
carefree kid are really over now sadness
can affect her core emotions just as
much as joy and there will be lots of
challenges in her life thankfully she
has a great team working hard in her
brain but knowing she's going to face a
lot of struggles and that they happen to
all of us is what makes the film's
hopeful ending so bittersweet ok so Coco
is absolutely gorgeous and Tufts on your
heartstrings but maybe just a little too
much after Miguel's adventures in the
afterlife he returns to the living world
and we know he won't see all the friends
and family he met until it's time to
move on celebrating Dia de los Muertos
isn't quite the same as actually
traveling to the land of the departed
it's a bit depressing to think about
them being separated from Miguel's whole
life but at least there's some bitter
sweetness and knowing he'll see Hector
and the others again eventually as Woody
and bo-peep share a bittersweet goodbye
at the end of Toy Story 4 what he
decides that it's just too hard to leave
beau Bonnie will be okay
afterbuzz tells woody that Bonnie will
be okay even without him he decides to
stay with beau instead of returning home
with his friends he even gives his
sheriff badge to Jesse while we'd love
to see what he growing we can't help but
hate that all our favorite toys are
going to be split up what does this mean
for any future Toy Story movies will the
toys ever reunite our favorite animated
robot movie wall-e has a beautiful
ending
[Music]
if you don't think about it too hard
let's face it the damage done to earth
is pretty terrible and it's gonna take a
lot to big are the people on the axiom
really going to be able to do it they
can barely walk after all we're hopeful
and happy that robots and humans have
found a way to work together but it's
going to take a lot of working out and
many years for everyone to be up to the
challenge when you think about it the
ending of Hercules is kind of like the
Little Mermaid and Cinderella after
spending the entirety of the movie
trying to get back to Olympus
Hercules gives it all up to rescue Meg
from the underworld and stay on earth
with her we're all for true love
but after Meg tricked him and worked
against him for the whole movie you'd
hope he'd think a bit more about giving
it all up for her but Disney really
likes to have true love win even if it's
fighting against logic the ending to
Ferdinand is pretty great if you don't
think about it too much
Ferdinand teaches us all dance isn't the
answer when he spares primero and in
return
Ferdinand himself gets paired and is
finally able to return to life with Nina
except so are all these other animals
I missed you dog well I didn't miss you
not even a little bit Nina and her dad
now have Bibles to take care of and
let's not forget the goat and hedgehogs
which thankfully take up less space it's
a good thing Nina's dad has those open
fields but things are still going to get
pretty messy with five Bulls roaming
around Cinderella might be the original
princess movie that most people think of
when it comes to Prince Charming's and
happily ever afters but it had a pretty
terrible ending the Prince tries a glass
slipper on a bunch of women and
immediately marry Cinderella after it
hits her sure Cinderella got out from
under her stepmothers roof and the
prince got a pretty new bride but
Cinderella definitely isn't the
fairytale love we all thought it was
when we were kids
honestly who can take care of a hundred
and one Dalmatians we were all happy
when the original puppies escaped from
the evil Cruella de Vil and brought 99
more puppies with them but now Roger and
Anita are supposed to take care of all
of them that's a lot of mouths to feed
and even
best dog owner wouldn't have over a
hundred dogs we're all for the canine
family sticking together but we kind of
hope Roger and Anita found some really
nice friends to adopt some of these
puppies and that they visit often of
course Chicken Little isn't the most
celebrated Disney flick but it does have
its fun and wild moments that means yes
I know the sky is however the ending
with Foxy Loxy isn't one of them she
gets zapped and turned into a
simple-minded southern belle and just
because a runt of the litter falls for
her they decide to keep her that way
Foxy Loxy doesn't even get any say in it
the effects were only temporary and Foxy
Loxy goes back to normal and maybe gets
a bit nicer on her own eventually the
ending of Monsters Inc is probably the
only time we cried watching a movie
about colorful monsters watching boo
open and closed the door looking for
Sulley after he's left her behind is so
heart-wrenching thankfully Sulley and
Mike figure out how to fix the door
but when he gets back we hear kitty and
then get no answer it's about time we
finally get the sequel Disney that was a
close one almost ready Dumbo is our pick
we're most depressing ending to a Disney
movie knowing what we know now about how
terrible circuses are for animals the
ending of Dumbo doesn't seem like a very
happy one at all sure Dumbo escapes
bullying and finally becomes the star of
the show but he's an elephant in
captivity who will probably have to
perform for the rest of his life it
might not have been a problem when the
movie came out in 1941 but watching
Dumbo now isn't such a happy experience
Dumbo and all captive animals deserve
better
which of these Disney endings was your
least favorite are there any you still
absolutely love let us know your
thoughts in the comments don't forget to
hit that like button and subscribe to
the thanks for more thanks for watching
and we'll see you again next time
you